- I saw this video of you
trying to teach your wife
a dance move.
So I'm gonna, I'm gonna play this.
(audience laughing)
So I'm just gonna, I'm
just gonna say, I feel
like her snap was like
a tiny bit off beat.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah. She tries.
- It's joyful. It looked joyful.
She looked like she
was having a good time.
Yeah. It might not have been in time, but
she looked like she
was having a good time.
- Yeah, my whole existence is just
trying to keep her on
the two and the four.
That's all. Just trying
to get her on that.
(laughter)
She claps on the one and three.
I don't know why.
- Do y'all sing as well?
Do y'all do karaoke?
- No. No, we're not.
Well, I, I, yeah, I do like to sing.
- I love that you led with that.
We're not singers, but
yes, I love Karaoke.
- Yes, I'm not a good
singer, but I love to sing.
And I do Karaoke.
- What songs you pick
when you? A 90's song?
- Since you been gone, that's my
- Oh my god, you just
wail on the courts. Yup.
- Just blow. Yeah.
- It's a good. It feels good to just
- It does.
- Yeah, and you know what, years later
even on tour, I'm like "Yeah!"
It feels good, just saying.
Like the first time I sang it.
Um, what's your go to karaoke?
- Probably Fresh Prince, you know?
'cause I know the words, you know,
- Oh, gosh. Yeah.
- We play that almost every day in here.
Oh, that. Oh, okay, I love that.
- I love that summertime.
Yes. That's the one I meant, I
meant summertime, Will Smith.
I always call him Fresh Prince.
His real name is Will Smith.